we have two lives
and the second begins when we realize we
only have one
if they spit at you behind your back
it means you're ahead of them
before you embark on a journey of
Revenge
dig two graves
there are one thousand lessons in defeat
but only one in Victory
when anger Rises
think of the consequences
if you are the smartest person in the
room
then you are in the wrong room
the funniest people are the saddest ones
the man who moves a mountain
Begins by carrying away small stones
we take greater pains to persuade others
that we are happy and endeavoring to
think so ourselves
a healthy man wants a thousand things
a sick man only wants one
people in ancient times did not like to
talk much
they considered it the shame for
themselves not to keep up with their own
words
he who knows all the answers has not
been asked all the questions
the gem cannot be polished without
friction
nor man perfected without trials
we accept advice and drops but we
distribute it in buckets
if what one has to say is not better
than silence
then one should keep silent
what you do not want done to yourself
do not do to others
study the past if you would Define the
future
you can overcome bad habits only today
not tomorrow
choose a job you love
and you will never have to work a day in
your life
is really simple
but we insist on making it complicated
think of tomorrow
the past can't be mended
give a bowl of rice to a man and you
will feed him for a day
teach him to grow his own rice
and you will save his life
it does not matter how slowly you go as
long as you do not stop
three things never come back
time word and opportunity
therefore do not waste time choose words
and do not miss the opportunity
a noble person blames himself and an
insignificant person blames others
it is better to light one small candle
than to curse the darkness
tell me and I will forget
show me and I may remember
involve me and I will understand
work on clearing your thoughts if you do
not have bad thoughts there will be no
bad Deeds
the man who says he can and the man who
says he cannot
are both correct
attack the evil that is within yourself
rather than attacking the evil that is
in others
to complain about an unpleasant thing is
to double the evil
to laugh at it is to destroy it
by three methods we may learn wisdom
first by reflection
which is noblest
second by imitation
which is easiest
and third by experience
which is the bitterest
he who flatters a man is his enemy
he who tells him of his faults
is his maker
to see what his right to not do it is
the worst cowardice
roads were made for Journeys not
destinations
your life is what your thoughts make it
no matter how busy you may think you are
you must find time for reading
or Surrender yourself to self-chosen
ignorance
Happiness is when you are understood
great Happiness is when you are loved
real Happiness is when you love
sometimes we see a lot but do not notice
the main thing
I don't understand how you can deal with
someone you can't trust
if the wagon has no axle
how can you write it
respect yourself and others will respect
you
don't criticize your neighbor's roof
for a lot of snow
when your door is not clean
if you hate
then you have been defeated
it is more shameful to distrust our
friends than to be deceived by them
forget injuries never forget kindness
there is Beauty in everything
but not everyone can see it
the man who chases two rabbits
catches neither
it is easy to hate
and it is difficult to love
this is how the whole scheme of things
works all good things are difficult to
achieve
and bad things are very easy to get
Learning Without thought is labor lost
thought without learning is perilous
learn as if you constantly feel you lack
your knowledge
and as if you are constantly afraid of
losing your knowledge
if you make a mistake and do not correct
it
this is called a mistake
the one who offends you takes away your
negative energy and gives you his
positive energy
learn as if you were not reaching your
goal and as though you were scared of
missing it
you cannot open a book without learning
something
if someone wants to offend you greatly
then it is even worse for him
our greatest glory is not and never
falling
but in Rising every time we fall
worry not that no one knows you
seek to be worth knowing
the superior man is modest in his speech
but exceeds in his actions
the man who asks a question is a fool
for a minute
the man who does not ask is a Fool For
Life